석유소 출구가 나가 오펙을 떠났습니다.
그런데 그 나라가 작은 산유국이 아니라
아랍에미리트라는 점이 중요합니다.
이 소식이 나오자마자 많은 사람들이 곧바로
페트로달러의 정마를 떠들어댑니다.
산유국이 오펙에서 빠지고
위아나나 빗달러 결제 이야기가 계속해서 나오고 있기 때문입니다.
그러면 자연스럽게 이런 질문이 따라옵니다.
이제 원유와 달러의 연결이 끊어지는 것 아닐까?
페트로달러 체제가 무너지고 달러 패권도 흔들리는 것 아닐까?
하지만 이 장면을 곧바로 달러 패권의 붕괴로 연결하면
중요한 흐름을 놓칠 수 있습니다.
핵심은 아랍에미리트가 무엇을 떠나느냐가 아니라
앞으로 무엇과 더 강하게 연결되려 하느냐입니다.
아랍에미리트는 오펙을 떠났지만
달러 시스템을 떠난 것은 아닙니다.
오히려 사우디와 러시아가 주도하는
산유국 조정 체제에서 벗어나서
미국이 제공하는 안보 보장, 달러 유동성,
AI 기술 네트워크 쪽으로 더 가까워지는 선택일 수도
그래서 이번 사건은 단순히 아랍에미리트가
왜 오펙을 탈퇴했는가에서 끝나지 않습니다.
더 중요한 질문은 왜 이 사건을
탈달러의 신호로만 보면 안되는가?
그리고 아랍에미리트의 선택이 앞으로 중동질서와
달러 패권을 어떻게 바꿀 수 있는가입니다.
먼저 오펙의 역할부터 간단하게 말씀드리면
오펙은 석유 수출국들이 생산량을 조절해서
유가를 관리하기 위해 만든 조직입니다.
공식적으로는 석유시장 안정이
목적이지만 실제로는 산유국들이
자기들끼리 유리한 가격 수준을 유지하기 위한
장치라고 보시면 됩니다.
이런 방식이 본격적으로 흔들린 시점이 2014년입니다.
당시 중국 경기 둔화로 아시아 원유 수요가 약해졌고
미국에서는 쉐일 오일 생산이 늘어나고 있었습니다.
수요는 약해지는데 공급은 늘어나니
유가는 떨어지기 시작한 겁니다.
예전 같으면 오펙이 감산으로 대응했을 가능성이 큽니다.
하지만 2014년 11월 회의에서 문제가 생깁니다.
사우디는
다른 산유국들도 함께 생산량을 줄이자고 요구했습니다.
그러나 러시아도 멕시코도 다른 오펙 회원국들도
적극적으로 줄이려 하지 않았죠.
많은 나라가 사우디가 먼저 감산부담을 지기를 바랬던 겁니다.
사우디 입장에서는 받아들이기 어려운 구조였습니다.
자기만 생산을 줄이면 시장 점유율이 있고
다른 산유국들은 그 빈자리를 채우면서
이익을 얻을 수 있기 때문이죠.
그래서 사우디는 감산을 하지 않는 쪽을 택했고
유가는 수직 하강하게 됩니다.
2015년에는 배럴당 40달러 대까지 내려가면서
생산비가 높은 산유국들은 큰 압박을 받게 됐었죠.
이때 만들어진 것이 오펙 플러스입니다.
기존 오펙만으로는 공급 조절이 어렵다고 판단했고
러시아 같은 비 오펙 산유국까지 끌어들이면서
감산 체제를 확대한 겁니다.
그러니까 오펙 플러스는 단순한 산유국 모임이 아니라
사우디가 혼자 감산부담을 지지 않기 위한
고통 분담 장치에 가까웠습니다.
그런데 이 장치가 아랍에미리트에게는 점점 불리하게 느껴지기 때문에
사우디가 혼자 감산부담을 지지 않기 위한 고통 분담 장치에 가까웠습니다.
아랍에미리트는 최근 몇 년 동안 원유 생산 능력을 크게 늘려왔고
앞으로 하루 500만 배럴 수준까지 키우겠다는 목표도 세워왔습니다.
여기서 문제는 오펙 안에 있으면 생산 쿼터를 따라야 한다는 점입니다.
더 많이 생산할 능력이 있어도 조직 전체의 감산 전략에 맞춰야 한다는 겁니다.
사우디 입장은 유가를 일정 수준 이상으로 유지하는데 관심이 매우 큽니다.
대형 국가 프로젝트를 계속 추진하려면
안정적인 원유 수입이 일단 필요하고
유가는 사우디 재정과 직결됩니다.
반면 아랍에미리트는 생산 가능한 원유를 더 많이 팔아서 현금을 확보하고
그 돈을 미래 산업에 투자하는 쪽에 더 큰 관심이 있습니다.
아랍에미리트는 두바이와 아부다비를 중심으로
금융, 물류, 관광, 첨단 산업을 오래전부터 키워왔고
석유 의존도를 낮추는 작업도 사우디보다 먼저 시작했습니다.
여기서 두 나라의 차이가 분명해집니다.
사우디는 석유 공급을 조절해서
아랍에미리트는 차라리 지금 생산량을 늘려서
시장 점유율과 현금 흐름을 빠르게 확보하려고 합니다.
둘 다 산유국이지만 앞으로의 경제 전략이 같지 않은 겁니다.
게다가 두 나라는 석유 밖에서도 경쟁을 하고 있습니다.
아랍에미리트는 두바이를 중동의 금융, 항공, 물류, 관광 허브로 키워왔습니다.
사우디도 비전 2030을 통해 리아드를 새로운 중동 허브로 만들고 있고
글로벌 기업의 지역본부, 항공, 관광, 첨단 산업을 관리하려 합니다.
글로벌 기업의 지역본부, 항공, 관광, 금융, AI 산업까지 키우고 있습니다.
이 영역은 아랍에미리트가 먼저 강점을 확보해온 분야와 겹칩니다.
결국 오펙 안에서의 갈등은 표면적인 문제입니다.
더 깊은 곳에는 포스트 오일 시대의 중동 경제 주도권 경쟁이 있습니다.
아랍에미리트는 더 이상 사우디가 주도하는 질서 안에서
움직이는 보조 파트너로 남고 싶지 않은 겁니다.
이제 미국의 개선도 함께 봐야겠죠.
미국 입장에서도 오펙은 늘 부담스러운 존재였습니다.
감산으로 유가가 오를 때마다 소비자 물가와 정치적 부담이 커지는 경우가 많았었죠.
아랍에미리트처럼 생산 능력이 큰 산업국이
오펙 규율에서 빠져나오면 장기적으로는 유가의 하방 압력이 생길 수 있습니다.
아랍에미리트처럼 생산 능력이 큰 산업국이 오펙 규율에서 빠져나오면 장기적으로는 유가의 하방 압력이 생길 수 있습니다.
당장 호르무주 해역과 전쟁 리스크 때문에 유가가 바로 떨어지지 않을 수는 있지만
시장은 앞으로 아랍에미리트가 더 많이 생산할 수 있다는 가능성을 반영하게 됩니다.
또 미국 입장에서는 사우디와 러시아가 주도하는 오펙 플러스의 영향력이 약해지는 효과도 있습니다.
러시아는 오펙 플러스를 통해 에너지 시장에서 영향력을 유지해왔고
사우디도 이틀 안에서 가격 조정자 역할을 해왔습니다.
미국과 아랍에미리트가 오펙 탈퇴를 조건으로 명확한 거래를 했다고 단정할 수는 없습니다.
하지만 양쪽의 이해관계가 맞아떨어지는 것은 분명해 보입니다.
아랍에미리트는 더 많은 생산 자유와 더 강한 안보 보장을 원합니다.
미국은 오펙 플러스의 결속 약화와 중동 내 우방 네트워크를 강화하길 원합니다.
그리고 이 네트워크는 이제 원유와 무기만으로 구성되지 않습니다.
미국이 아랍에미리트에 제공할 수 있는 것은
미사일 방어,
미사일 방어, 첨단 방지,
전산 협력, AI 인프라, 반도체 공급망, 데이터 센터, 그리고 달러 유동성입니다.
여기서 페트로 달러에 대한 기존 설명을 다시 볼 필요가 있습니다.
일반적으로 페트로 달러는 산유국이 원유를 달러로 팔고
그 돈을 미국 국채에 다시 투자하면서 달러 패권이 유지됐다는 이야기입니다.
이 설명이 완전히 틀렸다는 뜻은 아닙니다.
산유국의 달러 수입과 미국 금융 시장으로의 재투자는 분명 중요한 흐름이었습니다.
하지만 이것만으로는
달러 패권 전체를 설명하기에는 한참 부족합니다.
중요한 점은 순서입니다.
산유국이 원유를 달러로 팔았기 때문에 달러 시스템이 생긴 게 아닙니다.
이미 미국 밖에는 달러를 거래하고 빌려주고 운용하는 큰 금융 시장이 존재했습니다.
이것을 보통 유로 달러 시스템이라고 부르죠.
여기서 유로 달러는 유럽의 유로화가 아니라 미국 밖에서 거래되는 달러를 뜻합니다.
예를 들어서 런던의 은행이
달러 예금을 받고 그 달러를 기업이나 다른 은행에 빌려주는 구조입니다.
달러는 미국 통하지만 달러 금융은 미국 안에서만 움직이지 않습니다.
이 유로 달러 시장이 런던을 중심으로 미국 밖에서도 달러 예금, 달러 대출, 달러 채권이 빠르게 쌓였습니다.
이 시장의 중요한 이유는 간단합니다.
산유국들이 원유를 팔아 막대한 달러를 벌었을 때 그 돈을 받아줄 금융 시장이 이미 준비되어 있었다는 점입니다.
산유국의 원유 수입이 달러 패권을 세우고, 달러 금융 시장의 금융 시장의 금융 시장이 이미 준비되어 있었다는 점입니다.
산유국의 원유 수입이 달러 패권을 처음부터 만든 것이 아니라 이미 존재하던 달러 금융망 안으로 들어간 겁니다.
쉽게 말하면 원유가 달러 패권을 만든 것이 아니라 이미 강력한 달러 금융망이 원유 수입을 흡수한 측면이 큽니다.
이 관점으로 보면 아랍에미리트의 오펙 탈태도 다르게 보입니다.
아랍에미리트가 오펙을 떠난다고 해서 달러 시스템을 떠나는 것은 아닙니다.
원유 카르텔의 규율에서 벗어나는 것과
달러 금융망에서 벗어나는 것은 완전히 다른 문제입니다.
오히려 아랍에미리트는 원유 카르텔에서 벗어나면서도
미국의 금융, 안보, 기술 네트워크 쪽으로 더 가까워질 수 있습니다.
여기서 금융안전망이라는 말이 중요합니다.
달러 패권은 단순히 원유를 달러로 결제하기 때문에 유지되는 게 아닙니다.
위기가 왔을 때 누가 달러를 공급해줄 수 있느냐도 매우 중요합니다.
2008년 금융위기와 2020년 팬데믹 때 미국 연준은 주요 우방국 중앙은행에
달러를 공급해줬습니다.
쉽게 말해서 위기 때 우방국 중앙은행이 달러를 빌려와 자국 금융기관에 공급할 수 있는 비상통로입니다.
이 장치는 평소에는 잘 보이지 않습니다.
하지만 달러가 부족해지는 순간에는 매우 중요합니다.
미국의 달러 공급망 안에 들어갈 수 있느냐가 금융안정에 큰 차이를 만들기 때문입니다.
그래서 아랍에미리트 문제에서 봐야 할 핵심은 원유 결제 통화만이 아닙니다.
아랍에미리트가 OPEC 밖으로 나온 뒤 미국의 안보와 기술, 금융안전망에
얼마나 깊게 들어갈 수 있느냐입니다.
만약 아랍에미리트가 사우디와 러시아가 주도하는 원유 조정 체계에서 벗어나서
미국의 달러 유동성, AI 인프라, 반도체 공급망과 더 강하게 연결된다면
이 사건은 단순한 OPEC 탈퇴가 아닙니다.
중동질서가 원유 카르텔 중심에서 미국식 네트워크 중심으로 이동하는 신호일 수 있습니다.
그렇기 때문에 이번 사건을 볼 때 질문을 바꿔야 합니다.
아랍에미리트가 OPEC을 떠났느냐 보다 중요하다면,
아랍에미리트가 OPEC를 떠났느냐 보다 중요한 것은 아랍에미리트가 어디로 들어가고 있느냐입니다.
사우디와 러시아가 주도하는 원유 조정 체계에서 멀어지고
미국의 안보 부장, 달러 유동성, AI 기술망, 반도체 공급망과 가까워진다면
이것은 탈 달러의 시작이라기보다 달러 패권이 다른 방식으로 작동하는 장면일 수 있습니다.
과거 중동질서의 핵심 질문은 누가 원유 생산량을 조절하느냐였습니다.
하지만 앞으로는 누가 달러 유동성에 접근할 수 있는가,
누가 안보 부장을 조절할 수 있는가, 누가 달러 유동성에 접근할 수 있는가,
누가 달러 유동성에 접근할 수 있는가, 누가 달러 유동성에 접근할 수 있는가,
누가 AI 기술망과 반도체 공급망 안에 들어갈 수 있는지가 더 중요해질 수 있습니다.
결국 아랍에미리트의 OPEC 탈태는 페트로 달러의 끝이라기보다
중동질서가 원유 중심에서 금융, 안보, 기술 네트워크 중심으로 이동하고 있다는 신호일 수 있습니다.
오늘도 영상 시청해 주셔서 감사합니다.